hey guys how's it goin welcome back to
another cooking video today we're gonna
make one of my favorite foods ever so
I'm gonna try really hard not to screw
it up because I want to eat this
afterwards
today we're gonna make a simple salmon
simple and such as any salmon it's a
really special salmon
this is the wild Alaska sockeye salmon
say that five times fast from you're
saying all the WASC and sockeye seen
while while do you think Alaskan sockeye
skip here we go we got to get this
started
I'm using in a recipe from a lot of lots
of seafood calm prep time 15 minutes we
need the salmon we do need the salmon
yep whoa oh God
in my preparation for making my salmon
video I learned so much about salmon let
me read you a fact did you know that
more than 90% of the wild salmon in the
u.s. comes from Alaska I did because you
told me earlier okay we're Whole Foods
and I go up to the bar and I'm like
excuse me sir I would like some Alaskan
salmon and he's like okay like Jenna did
you know over 90% of the same it comes
from Alaska all right what do I got to
do we need cooking spray cooking spray
remove the wild Alaskan sockeye salmon
select from the refrigerator 15 minutes
before cooking preheat oven to 350 375 I
don't know how to I don't know how to do
that Oh
all right we're preheating right a
cooking sheet with cooking spray
that's a cooking sheet all right remove
the wild alaska Sakai's look about it
yeah back on step 1 you will oh my god
I've never cooked salmon before this is
like the first time ever I think I just
put it on we're gonna tell me to do skin
now I got fish look at this
it's skin look at that Wow it's like a
fish you heard it here first
it's like a fish how much does you
season there's no pepper on there that's
too much oh you don't know anything
don't we that's too much salt now let's
help a little more oh okay salt salted
it's been salted look at this snow
oh there's I get a bug in there mmm what
decide what we do next wine garlic the
butter and herbs I do have wine butter
get the butter some herbs
here's arms I I couldn't find very many
herbs and I actually had a Google water
herbs we tell you basil thyme oregano
cilantro those are all herbs I googled
it half a cup of wine
ok back up 1/2 teaspoon of freshly
ground black pepper this looks fresh
it's faced oh yeah what there's a big
hole here that's ok that's enough
2 tablespoons of melted butter okay
garlic 2 tablespoons of chopped fresh
herbs we have to chop them ok you know
how I'm gonna mince this is how I'm
mincing I'm gonna mince it like it's hot
and it's it like it's hot get the
blender out it's in here it's a great
idea
oh that's way too much I'm gonna add a
couple extra little spices just to taste
so we're just gonna we're going to blend
this nicely in the blender this is not
in the instructions whoa hey guess what
son necessary this
oh yeah you look good
great
places in the mixture over top of the
salmon drizzling and remaining liquid
time for the drizzle holy crap this
actually looks fantastic
whoa add more or less the taste okay
spray a cooking sheet this is it okay we
already did that huh please the salmon
in the oven for 12 to 15 minutes until
lightly translucent in the center it
will finish cooking from the retain heat
really does it matter which rack what do
you know about racks
I know something about Rack City put
that one set my alarm for 13 minutes
okay I set an alarm set my alarm for 10
minutes so we checked the Philips 10
minutes for doneness if you're new here
Philips is also the codename for fully
translucent tell me that I think it's
done which I've eaten enough salmon in
my day for this to look like it's done
don't know why I put inside that rack I
could have put it on top of it why did I
do that
I don't know fresh out of the oven let's
plate them up we need to plate them I'd
make a side dish sorry
so would I make my eggs with
placement is key Wow Wow I'm quite happy
with it all right here's a long
something's wrong like this looks really
good
oh did I make some right yes
but I'm so impressed with myself that I
don't even want to ruin my beautiful
beautiful masterpiece can we just for a
minute oh yeah ah got my Instagram
awesome so if any of you guys go to a
restaurant and get a lots of salmon or
you actually make it yourself please
send me a picture because I want to see
it to show you bash tag ask for Alaska
and yeah I'm gonna be looking for your
salmon pictures I'm so freaking proud of
myself I'm proud of you I'll put a link
in the description where you guys can
check out this recipe that I used and
yeah I'm gonna go eat this now see you
later
wait team can you guys just come here
real quick I just want to show you that
I made this I just need I just want I
want some more eyes to see something oh
wow you know I made it it's not delivery
is it Alaskan salmon Jenna good job yes
I'm so proud of myself